the White House is blasting the media
saying they took the president at a
context it's over Trump's comments
yesterday about heat light and
disinfectant and here's what he said so
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous whether it's ultraviolet or
just very powerful light and I think you
said that hasn't been checked but you're
gonna test it and then I said supposing
you brought the light inside the body
you can which you can do either through
the skin or in some other way and then I
see the disinfectant or it knocks it out
in a minute one minute and is there way
we can do something like that by
injection inside or almost a cleaning Oh
long so it'd be interesting to check
that so that you're gonna have to use
medical doctors and here is the
president reacting to the media coverage
and saying he's not encouraging anybody
to inject disinfectants I was asking a
question sarcastically to reporters like
you just to see what would happen now
disinfectant before doing this maybe on
the hands would work when they say that
something will last three or four hours
or six hours but if the Sun is out or if
they use disinfectant it goes away less
than a minute all right Greg I watched
this thing live as it came in and to me
I don't think he was being sarcastic it
looked like he was just spitballing
ideas to knock this thing out what do
you think well here there was a couple
of ways to look at this there are two
things that don't matter and one thing
that does was it take was it
off-the-cuff maybe doesn't matter what
sit sarcasm
maybe maybe not doesn't matter what
matters is that anyone actually believes
that he was saying you should inject
Clorox into people I mean once that
1,000 days with Trump plus as president
and we still have an entire industry
mobilized by an offhand comment how can
any adult believe seriously believe that
he was saying hey people should inject
chloride perhaps into their body I mean
I get wanting to believe that because
you have a pre-existing
addition to believe the worst about
everything that comes out of Trump's
mouth or to believe the worst about
anybody really I would challenge the
media one day to look at somebody they
don't like and try to assume the best of
their comments but it's it's I can't
believe that they're actually
interviewing experts so uh just tell us
yeah you can't put Clorox inject into
your body can you I mean people it's
this is actually a new cycle as other
stuff is going on this is hilarious yeah
I think Lysol released a statement over
social media one can you try to be fair
here you cannot believe the president
was telling Americans to put bleach down
near their throats I hope I think when
you said spitballing I think you're I
think he was riffing today I thought he
tried to get off the hook saying that he
was being sarcastic the press secretary
said he was taken out of context well
you can't do both you know so you got to
pick one and the thing is for me to see
him it at the White House in the
briefing room saying something like that
and believe me there was no gotcha
question there was no question at all he
was just as you say rippling spit ball
he just start came out with this stuff
and I think it's to some extent you know
for people who are listening to him
I think it's upsetting and dangerous I
just I can't I just you know Greg says
it's the media but I just think the
president needs to be presidential and
saying something like that I think it
invites disaster well I'm having dr.
Burks on my weekend show and I actually
asked her you were there dr. Burks do
you think the president was saying
anything dangerous and Emilee she said
no she said he was probably as he does
thinking out loud and trying to come up
with a good idea and just talking to the
person at DHS right I mean you guys it's
how Heather number one was killed in
heathers I feel like it's pretty obvious
you shouldn't drink bleach or the legs
that being said Los Angeles and Maryland
have literally reported that they've
been in and
with calls there are public health
agencies of people inquiring about it so
you know who who knows but I think it's
safe to assume unfortunately now that he
has to clarify all of his comments and I
do think however that the president's
continued comments at these briefings
undeniably just offer fodder for his
detractors to sort of attack and then we
discuss it in the news cycle and it's up
to his team whether at some point
they're gonna make the call it's no
longer benefiting him no I still think
it continues to benefit him but
obviously that was a big distraction
Dana from some pretty important news
from DHS director of Science and
Technology that outside in the light
were in high temperatures or high
humidity it has a very detrimental
effect on this virus yeah I think one
thing that I'm just setting aside all of
this and that's thinking about the
science and some developments there are
some companies and scientists that are
working on using UV light as a
disinfectant for like an airplane for
example or something that people would
go through the touch like when you're
going through the TSA lines and if that
is a development that could actually
work that would be a good thing not just
in regards to corona virus but for a
whole host of things so hopefully if
that development actually does come to
pass nobody is making fun of those
scientists because we do want to have
developments here and I would also say
if I take a choice between saying then
he was taken out of context which I
think that he was or being sarcastic I
think I'd go with the taking it out of
context but the media is always looking
for that so it's one thing that then
about the media but it's another one I
think the social media piece like the
individual people and the media leaves
there's memes and there's fun and
everybody jumps on it that's going to
happen if you don't have you know a
really tight announcement but that's
also just not who he is he wasn't
suggesting that people drink bleach but
also these companies if they weren't the
companies weren't necessarily putting
out statements because of what the
president said it's because if somebody
does it they'll get sued so that's one
of the reasons that you do that is
because you have to worry about your own
situation when the media comes after you
next
because somebody decides to do something
with your product that was inappropriate
but you know what Dana III noticed in
one of the companies actually was
responding to reporters asking about it
so it was like the reporters went to the
like the the head company to say yeah
can you you know whatever is this unsafe
so it was like it was the next layer of
the story we also have to remember that
when Donald Trump talked about sunlight
and talked about the summer and the
seasons changing that was declared as
non-scientific remember my just
remembering that why is Singapore seeing
an uptick then I that's the thing I just
don't feel I feel like every day we get
like today we've got six new symptoms
from the CDC we find out more that
there's like actually there's an
increases in Singapore it's like a hot
and humid there so I just feel like we
still just don't have enough information
and we're five weeks into this and we
all want to get back to work
and back to the city everybody could be
endorsed maybe the people in Singapore
aren't social distancing and maybe
they're not taking it as seriously as we
are